vous écoutez martinique la première idée
16h17 vous aussi ça aux cadis présenté
par alain niveau bonjour à toutes et à
tous l'invité de 5 à 10 ce matin bruno
nestor azérot bonjour bonjour alain
livory et merci pour cette précieuse
invitation vous êtes le maire de sète
marry you qu'a dit coca tremblay nestor
azérot oui les mots cadence et mara
tremblay compte monde puisque avant par
le rock radiohead en position corporelle
qui oblige autres troubles est nommé
like a dit qu payant 17 via séoul ou
next radio mais jamais mais seulement ne
m'a pas même peine en crète ses blagues
en ciel là le tout puissant mais sinon
au niveau des hommes pas du tout
personne ne vous fait peur ni perdant
dans cette conjoncture la de 2020
y'a aucun candidat que qui vous inquiète
mais monsieur livory ce sont des
élections
forcément je crois que c'est à la
population d'une manière générale de se
prononcer en fait le pouvoir
n'appartient pas aux hommes ni aux
femmes politiques
la dignité le vouvoie le met bien sûr
que dote d'un tour d'une manière
générale tout est toujours possible en
politique
néanmoins je pense que ce qui est
important aujourd'hui pour une
population c'est la visibilité de
l'action
donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui cette marie
avance
est ce qu'aujourd'hui cette maille se
modernise est ce qu'aujourd'hui cette
nice est un territoire attractif parce
que 7 mars est un territoire dynamique
c'est vrai de ces questions là il
fallait qu'il faut peut-être poser vous
passez de 6760 voire 2014 à 4648 en 2017
vous perdez 2000 voix votre popularité
s'effrite
il faut dire que les élections les
dernières élections municipales à cette
marée en 2007 à 2010 cette part dont
c'était le même contre le mip
tout le monde sait comment les choses se
sont passées au moment où j'ai été élu
député de la circonscription
nous savons tous que j'ai dû à vous
savez très bien que j'ai dû à revenir
aux municipales à sept maris et c'était
le même contrôleur médoc
en fait il ya eu une incompréhension et
a eu peut-être des événements qui ont
fait que les gens ne savaient pas trop
bien quoi faire
mais aujourd'hui depuis je pense que les
eaux se sont calmés et qu'aujourd'hui je
je en tout cas je vais à ces élections a
d'une manière beaucoup plus sereine
bruno leicester a cristallisé pas
quelque part un certain nombre de la
colère même au sein des agents de la
ville qui se disent en souffrance pour
certains les agents de la ville de sète
mariant souffrance bas du doigt c'est
une première pour but de nextradio
quelle souffrance des agents que depuis
que je suis installé à cette marque que
vous bénéficiez déplacé mais c'est tout
à fait normal qu'on désire hd c'est
quand vous dites que vous êtes revenu
mais monsieur lybohy vous savez très
bien qu'aujourd'hui nous subissons le
manque de contrats aidés vous le savez
et ce n'est pas seulement à sept maris
ce n'est pas parce que vous moquer d'eux
contrats aidés que le service public ne
doit pas être assurée donc vous savez
que fonctionnaire il est titulaire de
son grade pas de son poste
donc quand vous êtes maire d'une commune
vous êtes comme chef d'entreprise vous
avez une obligation de résultat vous
devez servir les populations donc jeudi
à 6 ou 4 nages à la boum était là pour
assurer un service public
je ne vois pas où est le problème
puisque dans une entreprise privée ça se
fait également mais ça peut causer des
problèmes l'accompagnait ah bon nous
pourrions accompagner nos services ou
humaine cette marie née en organisation
et pourtant à sur ce point de vue là non
pas d'amour pièce mouvement syndical y
est alors que les agents de la ville
sont en souffrance des agents qui ont
bénéficié du régime indemnitaire
depuis que je suis là des agents qui
bénéficie aux mois de juillet août des
horaires aménagés
kika travail seulement le matic baron et
l'après midi des agents qui profitent
des avancements des agents qui sauf qu
une grande considération et c'est ça que
vous appelez de la souffrance monsieur
livory ce que je sais faire moi qui l'
qui dit que enfin ils disent qu'ils sont
en souffrance mais monsieur livory ils
le disent et mon passé mais tant mieux
dit ça sur les plateaux sur les antennes
de martinique 1ère monsieur niveau c'est
quand même un journaliste averti l'un
est régionaliste professionnelle en zone
est allé ce compétiteur ça serait bien
de faire un micro trottoir
peut-être en mairie et interrogé en tout
cas d'une manière générale tout le
personnel et vous d'être précisément
ceux qui sont en souffrance
et puis leur demander pourquoi ils sont
en souffrance mais c'est quand même
paradoxal et c'est quand même bizarre
que le personnel de la ville de cette
marianne sous fausse et pas jamais ni
aux mouvements de groupes arméniens
donc c'est quand même bizarre alors
comment vous comptez mobiliser la
population et s'est pas amélioré l'image
qu'on que certains ont de vous une image
parfois négative monsieur livory au savs
ou en tant que journaliste ni démon qui
est mon démon qui permet aux nous
d'accord d'une manière générale
président la république landais mon
gamin démoli bien même c'est pas ça le
débat monsieur livory c'est à partir du
15 mars
et je suis persuadé que le 15 août mans
ce soir toutes ces questions là que vous
me posez
trouver le rythme parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui cette marie c'est une
ville qui qui se modernise à la vitesse
grand v
c'est une ville qui est au travail c'est
une ville qui a des résultats
vous savez la ville de sète marius et
sigouin la ville de cette manne
aujourd'hui c'est du logement social ne
se fait pas seulement dans le centre
bourg mais sur l'ensemble du territoire
dans les quartiers la ville de sète
marie aujourd'hui c'est le stade la
ville de sainte-marie 7e restaurant qui
vient de s'ouvrir qui va employer 80
personnes
monsieur livory aujourd'hui dans les
taux actuels sur le nord atlantique
quand vous avez la possibilité
d'embaucher 80 personnes qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi
et vous trouvez que ce n'est pas un
dynamisme d'un territoire monsieur
niveau il faut arrêter donc je crois que
ça qui était pas autant et j'en suis
persuadé que ses premières fois où quoi
ottoman voté cette marie et c'est
première fois ou quoi que les urnes peut
être gagné place pour mes débuts le
temps où et c'est peut-être la première
fois ou gamma d'où venait cette marque
dès cinq heures du soir parce que c'est
l'abeille constatant loba gailly
certaines associations notamment les
associations sportives se plaignent du
manque de soutien de la ville vous dites
quoi qu'elle soutient l'aller certains
fils en ciel à bord d'accord monsieur
livory vous savez ça lui gueddafi
aujourd hui j face à vous et que vous
questionner ce n'est pas jésus christ ce
n'est pas un seigneur tout puissant et
vous savez très bien aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement se dégage financièrement
l'inde et le gouvernement n'a plus les
moyens financiers donc lorsque nous
avons toujours pris l'option
d'accompagner et la samaritaine et l'as
mandé est hélas pas ce sursaut d ce sont
des associations sportives que nous
avons fléchés pour les financer il y en
a d'autres il y en a plein d'autres et
non il y en a plein d'autres mais je
sais c'est ça le problème c'est qu'en
disent elles disent web et ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui peut ce qu'ils
perçoivent et musées et puis nous voilà
on n'attend pas les miettes monsieur
niveau monsieur niveau il vous savez
très bien que si bruno histoire-géo
avait une manne financière qu'il ferait
beaucoup plus de choses mais je suis
malheureusement obligé de faire comme
mes collègues de faire des choix et
aujourd'hui nous avons des contrats
d'objectifs que nous sommes que nous
quand nous mettons en place avec des
associations
donc nous
donnons pas de l'argent pour donner de
l'argent nous donnons de l'argent à
condition qu'il y ait des actions qui
soient menées et qui est des résultats
qui soient obtenus c'est comme ça que
nous c'est de l'argent public mentionné
vous et je ne peux pas faire n'importe
quoi donc ne me demandez pas de donner à
tirelarigot à tout le monde alors qu'il
ya pas d'argent donc c'est pas parce que
c'est vous nous ne soyons et là c'est
pas parce que c'est un bouquet k way
dans une force supérieure quelques a
fait des miracles monsieur béliveau guy
et puis monsieur niveau vous savez une
chose quand vous m'invitez sur un
plateau je viens pour vous dire la
vérité je ne viens pas pour dire
n'importe quoi pour déblatérer parce
qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui déblatère
c'est aussi sur la commune de cette
maille comme par hasard mais vous avez
une réalité c'est que les yeux les yeux
ne trouve pas les yeux ramène à une
certaine réhabilité alors que les
langues peuvent déblatérer mais tout ça
en tout cas tout cela trouve à pau va
trouver justement ces résultats tout
simplement le 15 mars prochain
alors vous ne vous cachez pas vous
voulez être président de cap nord vous
allez livrer la bataille face à un fred
montueux le maire du robert qui n'a
jamais dit qu'il n'allait pas se
représenter
monsieur livory vous avez une chose et
nous sommes ne s'est pas eu de
démocratie ce sont les populations qui
décide donc si les élus que les délégués
communautaires votre robinet soit à zéro
je serai président de cap nau si les
délégués communautaires vote pour alfred
monthieux alfred monthieux sera
président de cap non mais vous ne pouvez
pas m'empêcher de caris & l'envi et de
vouloir porter maintenant de combustion
pour en tout cas le territoire du grenon
où est le problème c'est de la
démocratie
donc j'ai le droit de me proposer ma
candidature
tout comme les électeurs et les
électrices ont le doigt de l'accepter ou
de la refuser un mollet au vert pour
être élus sont les voix dit du robert
mais comment monsieur livres 57 délégués
communautaires ou là ou bien ces treize
voix
ok majorité et opposition
donc je ne comprends pas le sens de
votre question il est en campagne
vous parcourez les différentes communes
vous êtes en train de négocier
je suis surtout au travail a fait mari
pouvait pour continuer
la réalisation du stade pour continuer à
produire du logement social pour
élaborer des places publiques pour faire
plus de choses pour la ville de cette
taille je suis surtout tous les jours a
recommandé au travail moi vous savez la
campagne c'est pas parce qu'elle est en
période dévolu pour mener campagne pour
aller sur les quatorze électoraux et
tout ça monsieur livory dès l'instant où
j'ai été élu en 2008 maire de sainte
marie je suis au travail jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
il suffit de voir la transformation
souviennent et depuis bien longtemps de
la ville de cette page on va parler de
la politique générale on a vu que le
maire du prêcheur on a vu le maire du
prêcheur à la présentation de votre
candidature bien sûr et vous étiez
représenté à la rentrée du parti le pays
à oui d'accord mais nairas blanche manga
approchement entre les deux nominés ont
oublié j'étais représenter pour pour la
rentrée politique dimanche également à
madiana
monsieur niveau et nous sommes entre eux
martiniquais que ce soit ma seule et n'a
dû que ce soit lydia beaulieu en marche
que je sois les nous sommes des
martiniquais donc on n'a pas le droit de
se parler on n'a pas le droit de
s'observer c'est quoi vos idéologies
politiques ont récemment eu c'est
l'humain c'est travailler pour l'humain
améliorer si vous voulez cela je l'aï
pas la ja en baisse assez ou c'est vous
qui décidez non mais je vous pose la
camion monsieur livre ce n'est pas je
n'ai pas à répondre grâce à celles et
ceux qui ont eu à prendre et ça ce sont
les électeurs et électrices jusqu'à
aujourd'hui tous les combats auxquels
j'ai pu livrer tous les combats que j'ai
livré pardon ont toujours été victorieux
ayant noir or d'autres qui sont
victorieux c'est ça parce que vous ne
seriez au sambuc à travers la burqa par
les bla bla bla 100 boutiques à travers
ça vous dirait de la visibilité de
l'action elle est rien elle est visible
sur la ville de cette marque pas de roi
proche mans clair et net avec un pays à
monsieur livory sert pas pour l autre je
dis ah je me consacre aux élections
municipales
après les élections municipales ou à les
élections communautaire et peut essayer
après les élections dominateurs les
actions de la ctm danger notre changé
d'avis entre temps même après changer la
vie comme ont pu confronter à conforter
des avis c'est pas ça le problème depuis
le problème je l'aï toujours dit c'est
qu'est ce qu'on me propose comme projet
c'est le projet pour la matinée c'est
pas une question d'homme je l' ai
toujours dit et je ne change pas de
langage
c'est une question de projet pour le
pays ce n'est pas le cas sur deux pays à
damas ou 2x ou location d'un projet
qu'est ce qu'on me propose
non qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est bruno
nestor azérot je vous remercie
il n'y aura pas de sens qu'à dix pendant
les vacances de la toussaint reprise de
l'émission à la rentrée le 4 octobre
bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes merci alain livory ce sera
peut-être l'occasion de revenir sur des
5 à 10 dont nous avons entendu parler
mais que vous avez peut-être raté en
allant sur les podcasts vidéos sur votre
site martinique la première